well this is what's funny there's a
tweet from glenn greenwald i don't know
if you've seen actually let me see if i
can pull it up
because i i posted it on instagram and
uh i will in fact pull it up and i'm
ready i'm gonna expand on this uh this
this tweet from glen
great tweet glenn greenwald tweeted if
you think the real power centers in the
us
are the proud boys 4chan and boogaloos
rather than the cia fbi nsa wall street
and silicon valley
and spend most of your time battling the
former while serving the latter as
stenographers
your journalism is definitely ish
he's correct yeah so expanding on that
why is it that you know we rag on
democrats or like iran
democrats all the time because they're
the power structure in this country
the republicans don't do anything mitch
mcconnell is awful impeach the guy for
all i care he doesn't do anything
he's not helping trump supporters he's
fighting trump supporters he's not
helping the republican party he is
fighting against the people who actually
helped republicans win
in 2016 and the ones who did in 2018 and
2020
even though they did lose position a
position in 2018.
mcconnell and lindsey graham actually
hurt them right lindsey graham is seen
going on the
the you know the senate floor and like
fist bumping kamala harris when he was
supposed to be challenging her on a
bunch of policy issues
he's the republicans don't help republic
republican voters democrats are tribally
supported for the most part and
i i think it's fair to say republicans
and democrats get tribal support but the
democrats
actually do things they're proposing new
bills gun control
look at all the new gun control that's
that's on two new bills where's the
republicans putting up bills to rescind
gun control
right they don't do it they don't do
anything so when i when i when i've been
looking at all this i remember i was
talking to my mom about this
and and my mom was saying like you do
talk about democrats too much and i was
like okay what the republicans do this
week
i don't know what the what the democrats
do oh the democrats were doing xyz yeah
the republicans aren't doing anything
right what am i gonna say mitch
mcconnell did nothing again he's
obstructing oh that guy
the action that's taking place is what
you want to talk about but when you look
at the media they're still
obsessed with trump and with republicans
yeah and and the rhetoric coming out of
their mouth that
that the democrats helped feed the stuff
white men or the terrorists in this
country
it's why is nobody going after ahmed
yeah well now they they changed their
tune real quick it was really funny
there's this one woman she's like
she's like obviously we all know it's
going to be a white man a laga guy
and then when the news came out she was
like let's not focus on the identity of
this individual
because that will just glorify and then
when people are like yo
you're a hypocrite yeah she said
something like don't you realize that
even if he is muslim he's still white
like she had to like trip
did she did she set her twitter to
private yet that's what i always liked
to watch
listen it's from syria yeah okay
is it serious in asia i just want to
make sure i got my geography correct
let me ask you this why shouldn't uh
shouldn't
biden be getting blamed for this because
of bombing syria
yes yes a lot of so why isn't he
look man this is why i highlight this
glenn greenwald tweet
it's why i call out the power structures
there's a reason there's a double
standard we know who has the power and
what they're doing with it
joe biden bombs syria and then a couple
weeks later
some guy from syria who's a loner and
messed up
goes off the rails is there a
correlation there
they're ignoring it yeah they ignore all
of this stuff but they draw their own
correlations whenever they want
if this was trump this would be eight
days of don lemon
crying and then uh cuomo's uh
other brother taking naked pictures
outside of his house in the hamptons
to try and deflect this country
here's the problem and by the way i like
being able to sit and talk without
having to be funny
and just do fart jokes all day but let
me say this
uh this country strives to be
progressive
but it's not because everything that
gets done the next president tries to
undo
this country will be fully functioning
and damn near perfect when both sides
own up to the bs that they throw and
we're on an equal level playing field if
people held biden responsible the same
way that they held trump responsible
there'd be a lot more happy people and i
think biden should have run on like a
mega type thing but
m-a-a-a make america america ah
where am i i'm confused what do you
consider yourself politically
i first of all i can't vote because i'm
not a citizen yet
i did do the test and it turns out that
i am
a quote-unquote core conservative core
conservative that being said
uh gay marriage i believe in uh my
my things that made me lean to the
conservative or that
immigration should be done legally
because i did it
so it's people bring up with me like
well just because you did it doesn't
mean that's how everybody
i think you should have been able to
just walk through 90 miles of desert
without any
it's mostly snow up there i would have
to snowshoe i'm saying you should fly to
mexico and then walk in
oh yeah that works and hire a coyote in
canadian dollars
and then they just throw it away
yeah i don't i don't speak spanish i
just isn't that why i ordered my where's
the y
watch i got more uh porque esta no
donde good you're not speaking spanish
i think it is my my friends will tell me
it is yeah so
anyway that i was very pro-gay marriage
uh i think
taxation led me to be like the fiscal
stuff i was conservative on
and then the immigration stuff and that
and it was just like some weird internet
thing that we filled out on the show and
they're like
oh you're a core conservative can you
name uh how long have you been in here
in the u.s
nine years all right so can you name
some republican politicians you think
are honest
should we play the jeopardy theme
i can't really say honest i could say
people that i like and that i would like
to see
you know you don't think rand paul is
honest oh yes i do
yeah but i think he's also come around
because he was such a fringe player for
years
where people wrote him off but yeah now
he's great uh
desantis i like and i like the attorney
general
that spoke when they had to have a black
guy speak for the republicans and i want
to say barr but i'm not sure if that's
exactly who's the senator from south
carolina is that tim scott i think so
yeah
the black uh i'm not a big fan of most
republicans
like i said like mitch mcconnell the
fact that that guy just retains
a party leadership position is he is one
of the biggest roadblocks for republican
voters these are dinosaurs that are so
instilled in the system
it's like look i did a joke and i don't
even know if i can do it here
i said old white men are not necessarily
the best leader for
a progressive nation and then i say boy
i don't even know if i can say this joke
the fact that i'm doubting it how about
how about we save this stuff for them
save this for later remind me
only when we're allowed to remind me to
tell you about your two people running
for president
because the fact that i'm doubting it
means that you may look at me
really weird after well so i like to do
this thing where i ask people like
can you name an honest republican yeah
and
people usually give an answer it could
be because of the bias that our guests
have you know leftists don't want to
come on the show
but then i ask people can you name an
honest democrat and everybody's like
oh definitely not like i mean i think
bernie sanders is a little honest i
don't know
what was it honest when he went up on
stage and said if you're white you don't
know what it's like to be poor
when you're white you don't always like
to live in a ghetto maybe was it
honestly maybe that's honestly what he
believes
because he's a rich white guy well then
was it was he honest when he dropped the
word millionaire from his speeches the
moment
he became a millionaire from selling his
book did he he stopped saying
millionaire he says
the millionaires and the billionaires in
this country so then he just changed it
to the billionaires
yeah he's pretty smart i was pretty
honest removed it all right
i'm gonna buy his ice cream now i i
guess he brought it back
saying millionaires he just cut out
millionaires and just goes to the
billionaires
there was an article you're right
because the whole national conversation
changed to billionaires on twitter like
almost overnight how many billionaires
the u.s really
have look man you got 999 million
dollars and you're flooding politics
with it i got problems with that
yeah you're a billionaire doing the same
thing i got problems with that elon musk
what does he do he's building a
spaceship all right he's all right
you keep you he we don't we don't well
taxi ellen must you can keep your money
because he's building spaceships i think
the richer you
get and i'm not going up against your uh
tax the pedophile movie star thing that
you're coming up with in this weird
group chat
but i think that uh yeah i think rich
people
should be given a break why do you think
so like but define wretched because now
i've i'm i'm not rich but i work don't
take my money
stop taxing the thousand days and the
millionaire
i work hard but now it's like the harder
i work the more money i have to pay in
taxes
and i think i should be given a break i
think people should go hey aaron you've
worked hard enjoy it
i tweeted tax the rich then i tweeted
tax
uh hollywood millionaires and
billionaires 90 yeah and that
is basically like i think conservatives
will agree because they don't like the
hollywood
nobody does because they think tom hanks
has an ankle bracelet on and he's like
in a deep face
it's because you get p you get these
celebrities who use their money to
negatively impact politics that they
don't know
they know nothing about for virtue
signal points right so conservatives
don't like that when you see people like
alyssa milano coming out and using her
resources to just
negatively impact the country then the
leftists are like tax the rich i don't
care who they are they shouldn't be
doing this they shouldn't be flooding
you know politics into the zone
but anyway i want to make this point
there there's a few things i tweeted and
also these leftists are like shocked
i tweeted the trans flag with a with a
with a rifle on it
and it says defend equality and then i
tweeted under no
pretext shall the right to keep and bear
arms be infringed
i could there there's there's two
sentences the leftists like to say
under no pretext and that's a quote from
karl marx
who said under no pretext should arms
and ammunition be surrendered right the
workers should frustrate this by force
if necessary
for for americans there is the right to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
and i'm like hey we agree on this right
boom
combine the statement all these leftists
are like shocked like it's like no dude
you don't understand there's like these
statements are tribal signifiers
and they mostly offend people without
anyone actually understanding what it
means
do i think that transgender individuals
should have
ar-15s of any caliber and style they
want to defend their rights
yes should the black panthers be able to
march around with their guns
the constitution says yes 100
good honest law-abiding americans who
want to protect themselves from
tyrannical government
from criminals just protect their
families allowed to do it
and so it's like these leftists are
surprised because i think they don't
realize
how much right-wing individuals and
populists are not fascists and would be
like dude take your guns please protect
yourselves we want you to
yeah and when i say tax the rich i'm not
saying the dude who makes
200 000 a year or 400 000 a year and i
know many of the leftists do say that
i'm saying
i think about george soros the
conservatives complain about him all the
time right
okay well you also got the mercers the
koch brothers you got tom steyer you got
bloomberg
you've got right and left and it tends
to be many left wing and authoritarian
you know ultra wealthy
who are flooding the zone dumping money
into politics to subvert the rights of
the working class be it left
or right tax them i don't care i do
think there's a problem in just giving
that money to the government because
they're not going to do good things with
it either then it'll blow up kids in the
middle east right
but i wonder if we start by taking away
the influence of special interests
can we then start to chip away at the
government to regain
some control by getting rid of the
millionaires and the billionaires and i
mean the people with half a million like
half a billion or more
in terms of millionaire yeah i i think
you can take that influence out but then
you need to reshape everything and not
go
towards a military-industrial complex
and put money into education and money
into poor neighborhoods exactly exactly
that's a challenge
my wife tells me that all the time i'm
like tax the rich but the only problem
is when we do the government can take
that money and then go
gobble up kids and they're not going to
fix you know infrastructure
so that's that's the big challenge but
but i do wonder if
if we can get rid of you know the
millionaires and billionaires who are
influencing politics negatively and
subverting the will of the working-class
individuals in this country let's make a
list
a list of the uh the millionaires and
the billionaires i just love saying
let's make a list like all those
canceled people do let's make a list of
these people
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time